[Música]
aquí comienza ellas hoy el programa
feminista de France 24 históricamente
las mujeres hemos estado
subrepresentadas en las carreras
relacionadas con ciencia y tecnología
los premios Nobel han sido entregados a
más de 900 personas desde 1901 apenas
una veintena de estatuillas han sido
dadas a mujeres en las categorías de
física química y fisiología o medicina
Marie Curie se convirtió en la primera
mujer laureada en el año 1903 esa brecha
de género en ciencia también se entiende
porque las mujeres somos apenas el 30%
de investigadores en todo el mundo y el
35% de todos los estudiantes
matriculados en campos de estudio
relacionados con las ciencias exactas
cada tanto surgen iniciativas para
revertir esa tendencia y hoy vamos a
hablar de una de ellas el libro
peladitas de ciencias
Esta es una publicación que fue
realizada en Panamá donde se recogieron
nueve historias de pioneras en
nacionales en Campos científicos para
hablar sobre este tema Las invitadas son
la periodista e investigadora Vania
rocha y Eugenia Rodríguez blanco
antropóloga investigadora asociada al
centro de estudios políticos y sociales
y quienes además la coordinadora del
proyecto Muchas gracias a ambas por
estar en ellas hoy
gracias por la invitación pues vamos a
empezar Van y con el saludo para usted
de qué se trata peladitas de ciencia y
cómo nace este proyecto
peladitas de ciencia es la manera de
poder comunicar lo que investigamos en
pioneras de la ciencia es un libro de
veinticuatro pioneras panameñas en
diferentes Campos científicos tratar de
llevarlo a un lenguaje sencillo
y de y de relatos infantiles para para
niñas y niños de seis a nueve años
creo que con peladitas de ciencia es el
primer
la primera iniciativa que recolectas
solamente mujeres en Campos científicos
en Panamá y lo queríamos dar muy mucho a
conocer porque lo ha hecho países
Grandes como Argentina pero en
Centroamérica
creo que es la primera
iniciativa y yo creo que es algo que
todos los países debemos emular
muy bien Eugenia hablemos ahora un poco
por favor de de digamos el origen
profundo de hacer iniciativas como esta
Cómo es la proporción cuando hablamos de
investigadoras en el país de donde
ustedes vieron esta necesidad de crear
una publicación que genere esta
inspiración para las generaciones que
vienen
bien este proyecto
editorial literario y científico tiene
origen en un estudio una investigación
científica que desarrollamos hace tres
años donde visibilizamos evidenciamos
que Todavía existen condiciones de
inequidad para participar en la ciencia
para por las mujeres parte de las
mujeres y que esas inequidades se
reflejan en que las mujeres son menos en
determinadas áreas científicas y en
determinadas posiciones de la ciencia en
las posiciones más altas de la ciencia
pero también que a las mujeres les
cuesta más llegar y les cuesta más
también permanecer en esas posiciones
todo eso se explicaba con un análisis de
género que venía evidenciar que existen
roles y estereotipos de género todavía
muy fuertes que condicionan la carrera
de las de las mujeres y de las jóvenes
de las jóvenes no se no se imaginan como
científica
entre otras cosas porque esos
estereotipos
marcan con fuerza sus expectativas Y
porque también tienen poco referentes
este proyecto quería precisamente
abordar eso abordar
la superación de estereotipos de género
y la creación de referentes científicos
femeninos referentes científicos
femeninos y además cercanos porque como
ya se ha comentado Marie Curie es una es
una referencia incuestionable en
términos de mujeres y ciencias pero
pensábamos que era importante darle a
las jóvenes y a las niñas panameñas
referentes cercanos de mujeres panameñas
que fueron niñas en sus propios
contextos en los mismos contextos que
ellas y que se convirtieron finalmente
científica y además hicieron aportes muy
importantes para el país y al final en
mujeres exitosas ahora desde el
principio del programa estábamos
hablando un poco y dando ejemplos de
ciencias exactas pero Eugenia por
ejemplo ustedes investigadora usted
puede estar catalogada como una persona
que trabaja en ciencia entonces también
desde donde tenemos que empezar a romper
estos estereotipos que nos hacen pensar
que solamente una inteligencia
matemática es una inteligencia que nos
da para hacer ciencia no Estos son
trabas que nos hemos puesto nosotras
mismas a lo largo de los años
bien definitivamente los estereotipos de
género forman parte de la educación que
hemos recibido a nivel formal e informal
están en todas partes y son muy
difíciles de combatir pero no son solo
los estereotipos los que condicionan que
las mujeres puedan desarrollar Al mismo
nivel y y en la misma categoría una
carrera científica como los hombres hay
otros inconvenientes que tienen mucho
que ver también con el género por
ejemplo
como decía antes los roles de género la
sobrecarga que tienen las mujeres en
tareas domésticas y de cuidados la falta
de políticas de cuidados que permitan
que las mujeres que son madres puedan
compaginar puedan conciliar ciencia con
el desarrollo de
su maternidad por ejemplo hay también
todavía instituciones científicas con un
marcado sesgo androcéntrico sesgos en la
contratación de científicas en la
promoción de científicas el
cuestionamientos
a la capacidad de las mujeres por solo
hecho de ser mujeres en fin y sobre todo
una
una consideración
de género que sigue siendo muy
tradicional para para la participación
de las mujeres en la ciencia y ahí hay
que considerar mucho que todavía estamos
en una estructura de dominación
masculina que aborda todos los ámbitos
de la vida y también la ciencia la
ciencia es un hábito tal vez menos
conocido en relación a las desigualdades
de hombres y mujeres pero en la ciencia
también hay desigualdades también porque
estamos acostumbrados y porque lo hemos
normalizado mientras vemos la portada de
este libro que ustedes sacan para niñas
y para niños
háblenos por favor desde su perspectiva
de escritora de estas historias Pues
cómo fue trasladarlas a una realidad más
infantil y que nos permita a todos al
final pues tener acceso a la ciencia no
y a veces también recordar que pues los
libros para niños No necesariamente son
solo para niños a veces Son obras
cargadas muchísima sabiduría que a todos
nos hacen bien no
importante para el equipo era que las
los relatos infantiles
rompieran con esos cuentos de Disney que
todavía estamos los padres de familia y
madres de familia están muy apegados a
ellos y él los ves los escuchas
diciéndole a las niñas princesas
Entonces yo creo que esa dependencia que
hay en los cuentos de de hadas
queríamos romper con eso y dar a conocer
los relatos de estas mujeres y por eso
por eso Por ejemplo Tenía que estar de
cañón como decimos en Panamá el cuento
de elige Herrera era una fue una mujer
que tiene una historia estupenda
fue fue tan
perseverante que su doctorado en
geografía a finales de los de sus
cuarenta años
y ella tuvo un
matrimonio que llegó a su final porque
ya
quería estudiar geografía y ella había
apoyado tanto a su compañero en sus
estudios de Medicina ella Le consiguió
la beca para estudiar medicina pero
cuando ella quiso estudiar él le dijo o
estudias o no O se acaba este matrimonio
y ella decidió que estudiar Entonces yo
creo que esas esos mensajes potentes de
que las mujeres pueden de que las
mujeres no son dependientes era algo que
también
queríamos transmitir que era y que es
verídico de estas pioneras de la ciencia
en palabras sencillas para este público
infantil
bien y Eugenia usted nos hablaba un poco
de las estructuras de Cuidado como
deberían modificarse para que las
mujeres también aspirar a trabajos de
tiempo completo en las Ciencias y en
investigación pero también está esa otra
parte en la que nos han educado para
pensar que las mujeres no somos capaces
con las ciencias no históricamente
Entonces
no han pasado muchas décadas Desde que
la educación ha hecho esfuerzos por ser
menos discriminatoria pero pero tampoco
hay que ir demasiado atrás en la
historia para ver que a las mujeres se
nos enseñaba a coser a cocinar unas
habilidades que que de hecho eran
habilidades de cuidado y que no tenían
nada que ver con con nuestra completa
capacidad para ser científicas también
exacto de hecho me gustaría compartirles
una fecha muy importante
que es el año 1922 cuando Clara González
La primera mujer que se graduó en
estudios universitarios en este país
una conferencia en la que decía que era
importante la educación de las mujeres y
que ella decía ella misma como una
abogada defensora de los derechos de las
mujeres que no nos resignaremos a ser
maestras decía eso porque en la época
las mujeres solo podían aspirar como
mujeres instruidas a ser maestras ha
pasado exactamente 100 años desde que
Clara González dictó esa conferencia en
el Instituto Nacional aquí en Panamá y
si bien hay muchas cosas que han
cambiado hay otras que todavía
permanecen todavía permanecen como como
decíamos esos estereotipos que todavía
consideran que las mujeres tenemos menos
capacidades para desarrollar una
actividad científica y esto es que
demostró un estudio publicado un estudio
científico publicado en la revista
Science en el año 2017 decía desde los
100 6 años las niñas ya piensan que los
niños están más capacitados para hacer
referencia que ellas mismas que las
niñas son menos inteligentes y que la
ciencia es cosa de niños ese tipo de
cosas ese tipo de estereotipos tan
fuertes queríamos romperlos a través de
esta iniciativa teníamos Claro que
teníamos que enfocarnos en la población
infantil y que teníamos que mandarle dos
mensajes primero hay mujeres en Panamá
que han hecho ciencia y Segundo si
quieres ser científica puede serlo igual
que lo fueron estas pioneras de la
ciencia Pues nos queda clarísimo que
aquí el camino es la educación y por
supuesto que aplaudimos la iniciativa de
esta publicación así como todas aquellas
que puedan ayudarnos a descodificarnos y
a romper los estereotipos y los roles de
género gracias a ustedes Eugenia vani
por compartirnos un poco de ese
conocimiento y por compartirlo también
igual a nuestros televidentes sigan con
nosotros en France 24 nos vemos
Próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]